world-premiere
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
from the coalition please welcome studio
head Rod Fergusson
[Applause]
[Music]
13 years ago when I began my gears award
journey we had no idea how big this
franchise would become and as it's grown
we've dreamed of taking it to new places
in different ways to reach even more
fans and that's why today we're
announcing gears pop a collaboration
with our friends at Funko to bring a
unique mobile spin to the world of gears
and mobile is not the only new place
we're going I'm excited to also announce
the true Gears of War PC experience and
a completely different genre gears
tactics you create a whole new squad 12
years before Gears of War one has a hunt
a locust monster maker responsible for
destroying whole cities it's our take on
the classic turn-based strategy genre
with a character driven story faster
more aggressive gameplay a customizable
squad and equipment and of course that
wouldn't be as here's game without a
massive boss battles
we look forward to sharing more about
tactics with you soon but it's not just
about going to new places it's also
about having new experiences and the
amazing team at the coalition is working
hard to bring you our most ambitious
Gears of War title yet Gears v
as Kate has Kate your journey across the
biggest and most beautiful world we've
ever created with the war for humanity
escalates on two fronts outside the
capital city and within Kate herself in
this moment from the game kate leads a
rescue message to a remote village but
something goes horribly wrong
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you can't see you don't see this
[Music]
okay
I'm sorry
[Music]
thanks for coming here
of course can I recommend we maybe get
these people out of here hey just slow
down da foz is right we need to move
he's dead man give her a minute
she'll get her a minute in the Raven
that was wrong with you
don't we need to leave I'm not going
excuse me for months now I've been
having these dreams nightmares but I
think they were messages
[Music]
something's happening to me
to grandmother's enough we'll deal with
this later foster around these people up
they need help there's a place up north
I think we can find you answers there no
absolutely not
we have orders you'll go with me god
damn it both of you listen I'll go with
her
look if you're missing general notice
okay
I'll push Jack the coordinates they'll
corporal you're coming back to North
Fira
that is a direct order well captain
screw your order this isn't about you
it's about me I need to fix this
[Music]
Hey watch her a necklace that's a locus
symbol yes so she would never be harder
than me my choice I know that because
she would die for us I know that but
what if it's not her choice
[Music]
where are we going
who's ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey hey why did you come here with me
what did JT tell you
[Music]
[Applause]